okay hello everyone it's Michael BOS
from order flows.com and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Tuesday
May 2nd 2017 and today was you know kind
of aah day um not really much Direction
in the equities but uh you know
investors I think are reluctant to
commit to any direction ahead of the
fed's policy review and you know the
fomc meeting started today and concludes
tomorrow on on Wednesday obviously
Friday you have the jobs report so
that's another
big thing you know that's the one date
circled on you know every Trader's
calendar the first Friday of every month
and you know in light of the
recent the word it is recent Spate of uh
weaker economic data that's been coming
out you know I think a lot of eyes will
be uh watching the uh the non-farm
payrolls number on Friday and of course
over the weekend you have the uh French
election on Sunday so you've got another
uh I say Black Swan event but you got
another big event on the calendar um I
don't want to say Black Swan because you
know what you do have a French election
people know it and you know the only
people are going to say it's Black Swan
are are the people that lost um you know
it just it just kills me I mean like you
know brexit oh oh yeah had brexit the
Big Black Swan event well no you know
you have brexit and you know do you
trust the polls do you trust what the um
remain party is saying saying oh you
know it's it's going to remain and then
when it doesn't happen oh my gosh it
didn't happen this is the worst thing
that's ever happened
no you know it's on the calendar you
know there is a chance a very high
chance it's not like 99% against 1% you
know even brexit was was running very
close very very close so could gone
either way you know it's within the
margin of error and this French election
same thing if uh Leen wins you know
everyone's going say oh my gosh oh where
did this come from but it's there it's
there I mean even Trump you know I've
been a big Trump believer supporter
since the day he announced you know I
drove my wife crazy watching Fox News
almost every day she ah Fox News again
but you know what there there was a
message there
and there is a chance that he's going to
win it's not like he was a 50 to1 shot
you know he he
really I personally I think you know
like I said I'm a Trump trump uh
supporter believer you know I believed
in his message and I know a lot of other
people that also believed in his message
um you know it just kills me oh you
support Trump you're a Nazi you're this
you're that no that's not the case Cas
you know it's just whatever your beliefs
are um you know just because someone
doesn't agree with it does doesn't mean
that it's it's it's
the one in a million chance that oh my
gosh Trump won or oh my gosh you know UK
voted for brexit or you know in in the
case of the French election um you know
Leen Leen wins yeah it's just uh you
know you know it's on the calendar you
know it's there don't be surprised by
the outcome if it happens so again you
know with that with that said you know
there's a lot of risk that's coming up
this weekend and got to read the
disclaimer um you know again you know I
I know it bores people that I read this
disclaimer in the beginning of every
presentation but you know what there's a
reason for it okay and you know people
I'll get into it in a second you know
this presentation is for educational
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or Mak any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or
lifestyle only risk Capital should be
used for trading only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results and you again you know that
said you know again you know this is a
disclaimer it's there to sort
of kick out the people that you know are
coming to trading thinking thinking it's
some um you know getrich quick getrich
quick scheme you know or overnight uh
wealth is going to be happening to you
um you that's not what trading is about
and you know I I I I'm in some of these
Facebook groups on trading and and
believe it or not some of them are on
Forex you know I'm a Futures guy but um
yeah I laugh when I I saw this guy
posting about the French election coming
up and he's like oh my FX broker sent
out a message you know to be
careful and he's like all up in arms
like oh you know they're trying to
dissuade me from Trading blah blah blah
well yeah there is a reason for it you
know because your account can get wiped
out you know most of these FX guys are
are highly leveraged you know leverag up
to the gills and you know they don't
understand leverage they they think it's
um you know they think Leverage is the
greatest thing but it's it's not you
know it it works against you um you know
if you don't understand it um
so you know just you know be careful
um you know basically I'm reading the
message now the guy posts up I don't
want to post it up here because you know
I don't want to get banned from this
group or anything you know it's good for
a chuckle when I read these says uh if
I'm not mistaken I think the French
election is on May 7th my broker just
buys me there may be slippage that this
uh may you know the slippage and the
spread Etc may be
major you know he's complain I don't
know if this will be as big as brexit
one thing you know um blah blah blah you
know he's asking for you know people's
thoughts on it I mean come on you know
if if you've been trading in the markets
for any period of time you you know
what's going to happen you know you I
say what's going to happen you know what
can
happen when the unexpected happens so
again you know just uh you know what I'm
guess what I'm trying to say is you know
this week maybe bit quiet coming into
the weekend Friday and then you know you
might see some fireworks but then again
um be careful if you have any positions
on over the weekend you know is
basically what I'm trying to
say so the tools I'm going to use in
this presentation are the order flows
Trader uh footprint chart the Delta
scalper I'll talk about a bit and I
think that the Delta surge also has some
other things uh you know has some give
some signs today but you know I want to
talk a little bit about the Delta
surge it's
uh yeah it's something
that seeing that um what's how how to
say it uh you know people download it
don't read the instructions you know it
just kills me um you know I put on the
first line in instructions after you
install this the indicator please start
ninja Trader otherwise you know this
will happen or that will happen and so
on okay um let me I said answer the
door the Delta surge okay so it's an
indicator that's for free on the website
you know it's it's an indicator that
reads the delta in the order flow and
you know I I put it out there for people
to download for free okay simple
instructions all you got to do after you
install it restart ninja Trader okay if
you don't you it's not going to work
properly any indicator with Ninja Trader
after you install it has to be restarted
ninja Trader has to be restarted and
people don't do that they just install
it oh I got an error message it doesn't
work Mike you know your software sucks
this and
that fine okay have a nice life you
don't don't don't contact me about my
software anymore because if you can't
read the first line of the instructions
even I think in you know it's it
says
please please
uh please restart ninja Trader and
people don't for some reason they don't
don't read the instructions and again
you know with trading I'm going to show
you some examples with the Delta surge
on examples where it worked and where it
didn't work and it's a simple concept
you know that that people gets lost on
on Traders and you know I didn't write
about it in in the manual or anything
but to me it was something that was it
was so simple I I didn't think that I'd
have to put it in the manual on how to
take signals and you know I know
people are very indicator oriented where
they hey you know something says buy I
got to buy or something says sell I got
to sell no just because something says
buy here you got to read what's
happening in the market and I'm going to
show you the the example in a minute
um on on what I'm talking about okay
because again you know I don't want to
say it comes down to trading but it
comes down to a bit of I say common
sense but I mean if you're buying
something do you want prices to be going
up or prices to be going down for a
continuation trade okay if you're
expecting the market to continue in a
direction you expect the market to be
going up not going down right it's one
thing if it's a reversal
trade okay it's it may be a little bit
different but you know the Delta surge
is a continuation you're looking for
continuation so here this is an example
this is the Delta
surge you see the Delta building up in
here you know it's just sort of going
nowhere here previously then you got
2077 106 Delta surge kicking off green
buy hey Delta surge says to buy I bought
and you know it didn't work out well why
didn't it work out okay you're looking
for a move up all right and what do you
have you have this bar down you know
it's it's a red bar a bar Clos lower I
mean it's a Candlestick that's why I I I
use candlesticks I don't use bar charts
I'm a visual person most people you know
these days everyone everybody's visual
you know it's all Instagram Facebook uh
YouTube you know people don't want to
read or don't want to decide you know if
they could have an image in their head
you know that the brain processes images
a lot faster than it does um you know
words so you know that's why I use
candles and and you know it helps me out
a lot you know in the sense that I could
look at it make a decision hell of a lot
quicker than trying to look did the bar
open here and close there so anyway what
you want in this bar you want the bar to
be trading higher this individual bar
where you get the signal it's not it's
red it's lower that's not going to be an
effective signal yes I could have
programmed it in there to say only
kickoff off buys when the bar Clos is
higher than the
open I didn't put it in there okay it
wasn't in there to sabotage Traders or
anything like that to me it was just a
common sense thing um again it's it's an
indicator it's not a red light green
light indicator but it's an indicator to
highlight to me hey you know what you
have a Delta surge here things can start
moving now the reason how I created this
Delta surge or not say how I created it
but the reason
I I stumbled upon it so to speak years
ago trading palm oil Futures in Malaysia
okay people what the [__] is palm oil
well palm oil is is the most widely used
cooking people in the US will have no
idea unless they're um you know vegans
vigins Tree Huggers basically um will
understand what what palm oil is but
it's a major major commodity in in
Southeast Asia you know there's several
big Commodities in Southeast Asia one is
palm oil the other is uh rubber people
laugh about they say rubber trading
rubber um
but uh you know those those are big
Commodities you know it's interesting
you know comparing farming in the US to
palm oil production well palm oil has
gotten a lot better but rubber uh
production is is really has rubber
production hasn't changed in the last
you know since they discovered it you
literally you find you get the rubber
tree you put a little you know you
strike a hole in there you put a tin can
to collect
it that part hasn't changed but as far
as uh you know getting that piece of uh
rubber out of the tree then processing
that that that's improved a bit but
still anyway um you know the reason I I
created it is I say created it again
that's not the proper word uh the reason
why it exists is because on markets some
commodity markets uh it's when you're
trading on a minute based
chart okay this is a soybean chart um
you know soybeans you got a bit of
volatility but you know you're going to
get charts where there's just not much
happening you know in this case your
high to your low is about 4 cents but
you know in some markets especially if
you're trading a minute based
chart the chart could be going nowhere
you know it could be basically looking
like this here down here okay this is a
better example sometimes you get a
minute minute charts you know if you
ever traded a minute charts you'll know
what I'm talking about a five minute
chart where it looks just like this not
even maybe it's even tighter than this
you know and you got some bars basically
the whole entire bar for the 5 minutes
is the bid and the offer like that you
know maybe one other tick up um and it's
going nowhere so what I had to learn to
do is is read what was happening in the
individual buying and selling of the
market okay is it um you know is buying
picking up you know is there a big
seller things like that you know that's
you know I trading technically I was
trading with order flow even before a
footprint chart you know a footprint
chart came in and you know thank you
Trevor and the guys at Market Delta that
came up with the footprint chart um you
know know kudos to you and you know but
cuz before you know I just looking for a
way to try and pick up what was
happening um in there and you know you
can see uh we don't see it here but uh I
don't think there's a Delta search on
that Palo but on the soybeans but you
know if you could see you know see the
Delta expanding you know 30 minus 30 71
148 you know even though this is not a
Delta search say this was 5 71 148 I
mean you know you could you could read
into it you know you say okay you know
you're going five is getting bigger here
you don't really care that it's a red
candle you got positive Delta which is
encouraging if you're at a low you know
you have to see positive Delta if you're
going to move away from a low you're
going to need to see positive Delta
you're going to need buyers to come into
the market and then you they see W 148
okay you know even though we're not
going anywhere you know buyers are
taking control of the market and you
know you just going to go nowhere then
boom you get the you get the little bit
of a move up now in in you know in some
Market again like palm oil you're lucky
to get uh two or three moves a day in
that market honestly you know sometimes
you get a bit more but there's really
going to
be um you know two or three nice moves
and if you get you know two out of the
three that's good um there'll be some
small like little moves like this where
you come up a little bit but um you know
there's in some of these commodity
markets you know you know you just don't
get the big you know you don't get the
big swings up big swings down as you
know in in other markets people say Well
then why you trade palm oil well I
managed a palm oil book and you know
that's what I had to trade I had to
trade palm oil bean oil soy meal soy
beans all these contracts um so it's you
know it's just you know anything that's
going to give you an edge Delta gives
you an edge is Delta is something that
very few people are looking at in the
market and you know if you just ignore
it or don't use it okay then you know
like I said you know good good luck to
you you know if you got a way of trading
then then fantastic but you know if
you're a neoy to trading and you're
looking for something that you know is
going to give you an edge then you know
look at
Delta Delta is a great tool and again
you know it's not something that's
widely accepted by lots and lots of
Traders out there but still um you know
you could use it so anyway you know you
get a Buy Signal right again you know
indicator people say I got a buy signal
I got to buy I don't care if the bar is
going up or going
down no well why not you know if you're
buying you want the price action in the
bar to be going up so here is not this
is not a good
signal um I won't get into these but
this is the Delta scalp we're giving a
buy Delta scalp we giving a sell there
again you got the Delta surge right here
this green line this green thing it's
green arrow green zone so to speak but
it's a red candle even though Delta was
expanding price price action of the bar
is telling you otherwise so be afraid I
say be afraid be hesitant to D this
trade and what happens it fails you know
people say oh you know Delta scalper you
know you had two trades this morning
they both failed well dissect it why
does it fail well I'm trying to buy but
the candle's going lower well okay why
are you buying if the candle's going
lower you know you're buying it here
it's like trying to catch a falling
knife that's your um metaphor
uh this is the Delta scer here giv a
nice little buy again so you know Delta
scer is working nicely in this market so
here you got the Delta surge again now
you got green candle okay it's giving
you a buy you'll say oh this one failed
yeah it failed um you know it probably
would have come down here stopped you
out before making the move you know it's
just unfortunate you got a bit of
selling coming in
there but again you know the other thing
about
this s about trading um that people
go uh go Miss on is where the you know
context of the market okay so what do
you got here okay let's just sort of
back it up you have a low here
10913 10938 you're getting a Buy Signal
well do you want to take a Buy Signal so
far off you know after a big move up
like
this I mean you know some people yeah of
course but you know honestly if I'm
looking to buy I'm looking to buy
somewhere closer to the low of the day
you know the Delta surge is up here this
one the Delta scalper is down here
actually um Delta scalper and Delta
scalper and Delta surge completely
different they both read Delta but how
they read Delta is different um in case
you're wondering I'm not going to get
into the mechanics of it but it it is a
bit different you don't you very rarely
get ever get a Delta Sur you're not
going to get Delta Surge and Delta um
scalper at the same at the same level
but Delta scalper exists to find excuse
me find you know shifts in supply and
demand okay that's why you see it you
know right at this turn so you see it at
this turn you see it at this
turn and then again you got it up here
this is already 2:00 here but again you
know context some people say well you're
filtering out you know you're Buy buy
only on up bars you're selling on down
bars you tell me not to take it at uh
ends of moves oh it's too confusing I
don't want to I mean come on be
realistic in
in in what you're understanding can the
market go you know you just had a big
move from your low from 13 up to 38 you
know what is that 25 tick move is that
25 ticks yeah 25 tick move in the in the
in the euro currency and then you're
getting a Buy Signal yeah you're getting
a Buy Signal because it is reading the
Delta and it says yeah the Delta's given
this here now if you know anything about
how the market tops you know you might
be a little bit careful but you know
whatever um you know I could sit here
and explain people all the intricacies
of of the market but you know people
don't want to take the time to
understand you know understand trading
understand how it's How the markets you
know work you know sometimes you know as
you getting up near a high you get
blowoff volume you know big Delta you
know at this point honestly
the reason why I'm not interested in
taking it okay I'll talk about it
because people say well you know he's
saying you know this trade failed so he
said not to take it you know he's going
back on it no okay you have this move
from your low okay look 13 or where is
it down here 10913 down here okay you
trade 25 ticks higher a lot of [__]
going on in the market all of a sudden
we're coming back up here a lot of
people retail people are coming in oh I
didn't buy you know now now they're
coming in they're buying I don't want to
miss out on this move all of a sudden
they're buying it here you know thinking
we're going to go up to this High cuz
high is not that far off High's up here
at 51 just have a 25 tick move from the
low we're trading 38 you know 41 10
ticks off that high say oh we're going
to take out the highs we very well be
now are they coming in a bit late yeah
these people I think are coming in a bit
late and you know you got some sellers
up here and it just you know these these
buyers that came in got in late they
bought there's no more buying
and sell it you know the market just
drops
here then then it makes its run up a
little bit later but you know so these
guys are they are they stuck and they
got to get out I don't know you got
heavy Delta here so these people that
were buying it here looking for the move
higher you probably selling in here you
got Delta minus 400 where else they got
a negative Delta 400 on the sub move you
don't you know so all these people that
were buying it looking to go up you know
are stuck you got buying and balance
buying and balance buying and balance
then you got selling and balance selling
and balance bounce when we're not going
higher you know that's that's what you
know I hate to use the term trap Traders
but you know Traders are stuck in a
position that's what it looks
like so you know hopefully you could
understand that again you know yes there
is a signal here but again take it in
context of the market you're getting a
Buy Signal after 25 tick move in the
eurocurrency you know what's the range
in the euro currency today for the most
part going up until you know just before
you know 109 50 we'll call it well we'll
call it here 55 A2 30 is the
low yeah that's 42 and a half ticks and
that's even after making this new high
later so you know before that we'll call
it uh 51 so 51 minus 13 it's 38 38 ticks
up to this up to this High here and you
just had a move of 25 ticks so about 2/3
of the way and then you're getting a Buy
Signal you that's not the best trade
location I mean yes you can go higher
and we did but you know realistically to
get a Buy Signal you want to get it a
little bit lower on the day structure
than somewhere up up near the High um I
talk about snps real quick snps were
watching paint dry this morning really
really
was uh I was in I was in the
room and honestly I felt like uh I felt
like I was asleep actually uh so going
into you know 8:30 the cash open and
here this was you know 7:00 deadly tired
this bar here from this is a 4 range
chart this tells you how slow it was
four range chart you got this bar 521
then 607 so you know 40 minutes there
another hour almost between the next bar
things is I didn't expect things to pop
things to start moving once the cash
opened and it did we made a new high by
two ticks you know started coming off
boom you got a lot of selling coming in
here and you made new lows
okay and you see that the the Delta's
you know strong - 3,000 - 2,000 which is
a little bit opposite of these highs
okay so you know are these
highs going to be taken out and go
higher well I mean you got a couple
divergences which is a sign that maybe
we could but you don't have very strong
Deltas up here at the high that we can
go higher but you coming down into the
lows you got strong Deltas okay maybe we
could go lower how much lower we only
went lower by about a about a point um
and then you're just sort of hanging
around this low and it's this was a
little bit flurry of activity then it
started slowing down again um this is a
ratio with a
Divergence point of control towards the
bottom but you're running up into you
know another ratio here you come down
again you know the Delta scalper here
this one it didn't work um but you're
sign that might not work is here you got
a Buy Signal you got a bunch of buy
signals here but then boom it's met with
a cell signal you know a bearish sign um
this is the uh this is the the U-turn
telling you that hey you know this
Market could be this could be a low and
you just go sideways got the selling IM
balance now the selling IM balance it
was interesting because it didn't work
in the sense that um you know it was
never really in the money this bar
started out then it just turned green
went back up into the zone Green again
above the Zone above the zone five
levels you know you it could draw it out
however many levels you like I like five
if tra's not working out by the third
the third bar is probably not going to
be very effective um this is the U-turn
again you know we trade
down again you got the Delta scalper
here you also you got the transition um
then you start rallying a bit you know
you got this cell this U-turn here this
one didn't work
out but as you notice all sudden now
you're starting to see some strong
buying come in and again you know going
back to the
delta the Delta surge you know on on
markets that are going nowhere like you
can see here you know this
is in a sense Delta surge actually here
with this increasing volume 87 322 225
it's not because I have other I have
ways that I like to discern it I don't
like to discern it in the sense of a
bunch of bars with positive
Delta because you know in the middle of
a bunch of bars with positive Delta
you expect Market to go up um if it's a
Delta surge buy or you know if it was a
Delta surge cell with negative Deltas in
the middle of a bunch of bars with all
negative Deltas I'd expect the market to
go lower but
anyway you know like this you know so
Market is going nowhere you know if you
can see the Delta increasing you know
that's a sign to you and you get a
little pop up
here point of control you got a ratio
you again the market doesn't do anything
comes right back with some very strong
positive Delta so the one take away from
this little bit of a move you look at
these buy and balance 2900 2300 just
stack buying and balance 1300
3,000 okay it looks like a market that
wants to go higher honestly and you even
got a little bit more followup in there
um but that doesn't it doesn't it keps
you know within 3/4 of a of a point of
the high and then just it just keeps
going sideways comes off you know this
is 2:00 already it tells you how boring
this Market was this is the Delta surge
again here right here this green one so
you got a green bar back here you got
the green bar here where the signal is
this is what you know ideally that's
that's how you want it right I don't
care about the first bar second
bar but for a buy I want the bar to
close red if it was a sell that's a
search sell I'd want the bar to be red
and you know you can see here you're
sort of bottoming out okay which is nice
you got Delta increasing which is nice
and you get a little bit of a move
finally I said you know this Market
you're talking a range of 81 and 3/4 to
88 and
3/4 so that's what a
seven seven point range for the day
Waring and you know so you can be buying
it around 84 you get a bit of a move up
to you know 87 you you're catching half
the range which is good so again you
know take this in context right this is
closer to the low than it is to the high
like the the eurocurrency one I showed
you earlier eurocurrency one happened
right after a move up a big move up this
is happening on a move down and then the
Market's bottoming out and starting to
turn up you know I mean
it's it's there's a phrase you know I
heard someone else that that has
another sort of overflow software out
there on the market and he's talking
about oh you know institutional traders
buy at uh at wholesale prices retail
Traders buy at uh retail prices well
yeah no um you you can see how the
Market's coming down here let's even
look at
this uh where is that let's go back here
the market turned here it traded 53 Lots
traded 600 300 300 you know that's not
big volume down there yeah granted here
you got 2,000 but at every level in here
you're getting a couple thousand so you
know come down here and say oh you know
institutional Traders were big buyers on
they weren't they traded 53 Lots
here you know maybe they were on the bid
there who knows um but it's not like
they're all coming in and supporting
that market you know at any given time
you know the market came up here and
turned up here you know TR on 237 at
that High um then you know so there
there was a decent move here um a little
bit of a move to be had there wasn't
much opportunity in this market you got
a seven-point range in the snps I know
there I'll get an email from you know
some of these other trading rooms oh I
had a 15o day in the snps oh how the
[__] he gets 15 points out of of a range
you know you must be a a guru Trader a
Master Trader if you get 15 points on a
day like today and I'll probably get
some he he may say oh I got yeah I got
10 picks out of the 10 points out of the
move out of the snps today you suck uh
Volos so whatever um you know there's
always going to be these uh detractors
and uh so anyway let's look at some
other markets really quick I'm going to
look at crude I don't really remember
much happening in the crude this morning
I did sell off a bit later but uh where
do I want to look at here go
back again okay so you know 5 in the
morning you got the Delta surge given a
buy at the high of the day do you want
to take it you know again I I don't
think it's prudent to be taken
um you know buys at the high yes you can
you can buy the high if you want you
know Market can go higher as you see
here does go higher I used to be a big
breakout Trader in the past not anymore
um I do buy highs sometimes and yeah I I
personally I I do I try to trigger stops
you know and it only takes one lot to
trigger a stop so if if if I think we're
coming up on a level I might poke
it uh I got the Stacked and balance
let's take a look at what other
interesting things were here Delta
scalper here didn't work out bar came
right back down
Delta scalper again this time cell um
they could have got something out of it
now this is interesting here very
interesting that what what is occurring
down here in the crude
and you know before I go into what
happened there but here you got the low
of the day you got aggressive buying
buying stack buying and balance you I I
like that you know I like reasons to be
buying it off the lows and if I can get
buying and balances off the lows
unfortunately it just goes sideways on
you it makes a new low by two ticks and
look what you got down here 1,000 you
got a A selling imbalance 1,000 Lots
here you know you got a ratio bounds low
as well and you know when you get
selling IM balances at the bottoms of
bars you know watch for a move higher
and you get it
now 1,000 this is interesting what's
going to happen if we hit that level
again okay we we rally
up all the way up to
6870 start coming down you got
aggressive selling this is now you got
the Delta surged here going into the low
again I'm not a big fan of this that
those areas but I'm curious at this
point you know we traded a th000 there I
know there's 4850 is a level again you
another trade at, 1500 if we get past
this level this is you know an area that
I'd be interested to sell honestly if I
if we get past this level you had 2 and
a half thousand there I think you know
hly if we get past that level I would
expect the market to go lower honestly
I'd expect it to go lower a hell of a
lot faster rather than sort of get this
bounce up and then go lower
um but I I I this is the type of low I
would be interested in selling honestly
it it's it's something that you know
it's hard to explain it's something you
know it's a lot of my years of
experience on looking at at the market
price action around highs or lows uh
when there's a big support level yeah
I'd be interested in selling it there
but honestly I'd be expecting the move
to happen much
faster rather than sort of bounce back
up through the level and then go lower
I'd be Looking For The Straight move
down from here down to here uh pretty
quick 25 C move more or less pretty
quick but it was interesting we got
through this level you know you have all
this yeah a couple bullish signs here
but the Market's not able to move
instead Market keeps being pulled
towards this level here at 4850 and if
you get past that level watch out so we
do we go
lower get past this other level down
here 4825
boom this is what a stack you see have a
stack imbalance but this is what a stack
imbalance triggered by a stop looks like
you know this is what I would like to
see here when we broke through this 4850
level up here this is really what I'm
interested in in getting and if you've
watched enough
markets often times you can get moves
like this this is the move I was looking
for up at
4850 but it it didn't happen up there um
it just happened happened a bit later
you get a little bit of a pullback boom
um but just uh you know stronger selling
stronger
selling you just even going down into
more lows more lows more lows there's
really no reason to be buying on this on
this move lower in the order flow um
there was one this no
um yeah no no reason here no reason on
this move down
no reason we be a buyer
yet yeah okay so here you have the big
move down here you got the Delta surge
you know possible buy okay yeah I would
have bit honestly
um but it came right back down you know
you have it's met with some decent
volume up here 1,500 500 500 so I still
know that there's there's sellers up
here okay so why is this important is
because we hit a low here
4749 you know people going say hey how
how could you determine that there
sellers up there well if you look at the
if you look at the volume 500
1,600 500 know granted the time it's
1:00 but on this move up are there any
sellers like that here yeah here on this
move up it's a green bar but you we got
through it here it's a red bar it's not
working out we can't get through these
levels do you see a th000 dc500 at any
of these levels on this move back up so
obviously there's still sellers in the
market they're looking they're there
looking for the bounce up and the bounce
up is
happening and they're taking their
opportunity to sell
more okay and you know after
1:00 already um come back up again yeah
you got some heavy volume up there and
the market just continues on
down but uh anyway let's take a look
at know bonds this morning were actually
kind of boring as well um fomc
meeting you know it's going to be tricky
trading the bonds um it's not like
they're going to be leaking out any
state Secrets during the FMC meeting but
uh anyway in the bonds you know this
morning you have this High here you got
the Delta surge kicking off right on the
high but it's not the most going to be
the very effective thing because one
it's at a high two it's a red down
candle which is not an area where I like
to be you know I don't like taking buys
on on red candles then it comes back up
here now this was interesting
here again this is this bar you got this
uh selling imbalance here so you know we
hit the high started coming off people
that were buying it looking for the
market to go higher all a sudden hey the
Market's not going higher they're
selling they're selling it here it's SP
with Buyers boom then you get point of
control at the bot you point of control
right near the bottom Point control
right on the bottom so you got some
support in this market here and you know
we just go up we make new highs yeah
we'll be by a couple ticks and then we
just go
sideways sideways sideways a little bit
higher now
you have a Divergence a Divergence I'm
not going to say these failed yet
because you know we're still at the high
and then we start coming back up we test
the high again boom and then we see
supportive buying coming into this
Market here here here we go higher you
got another Divergence you got three
divergences three fail divergences in
this case though they're a bit spread
out though um this is 11:30 these are
9:00 but you know on a market that's
going to Trend
higher you you're going to have failed
divergences on the upside and on a
market that's trending
lower you're going to get failed
divergences on the downside and I mean
that's just a sign of of a of a trending
market and you can see Bo we start going
higher you got aggressive buying coming
in and you know we end up day uh much
higher
okay what other one anyway I haven't put
the transition up there but uh you know
I do know there's people using it and
you they said hey show me some charts so
again you know transition this is a mini
da 100 tick
chart mini da you know it's it's best to
trade it during cash hours you know 8:30
here so you know even though you got a
couple signals there I'm not really I'm
not interested in it honestly go oh you
know cuz it failed no manyi da the most
activity is going to happen during when
the main underlying cash markets open um
I mean don't
be don't be an idiot I mean it does
trade decent volume but the major the
real moves with heavy volume are going
to be happening during the
cash during the cash hours so 9:00 just
for 9:00 you got a buy here yeah that
worked out nicely the sell didn't work
out and you get another sell up here um
it worked out sort of pulled back up
there a nice little buy here so again
you know it wasn't the biggest uh day in
terms of movements but there there were
some trades to be had you know nice
little sell here right on the cash close
this one you wouldn't be taking it's
right down the Futures
close and what other charts do I got to
show
well you know just really quick again
you know daily chart on the snps how
does it look this is how it looks daily
chart boom just going flat sideways very
tight um well this is yesterday this is
the night session right now very tight
range here very very tight range inside
yesterday's range um and we're just you
know just in know holding pattern I
think until uh I say until next week but
probably until uh probably until next
week again you know you got that French
election over the weekend and you know
if you remember what happened on the
last uh a week or two ago this is what
the market did when the results came out
from the French election you gapped up
you know from you know cuz the the day
the the Friday before was you know was a
down day so 47 and A2 we opened up
almost 20 points higher um and so we
we'll see it's not all due to the French
election there was some other um you
know there was no nuclear war with North
Korea over the weekend which also I
think helped you know at that time
there's a lot of Sab rattling but anyway
um I don't want to make this too long
for people it's already 40 minutes so
thanks for watching this video again you
know this is the this is the sales part
to learn more about orderflow trading
and the trading software used in this
presentation visit orderflows
docomo flows.com and to learn more about
the Deltas scalper go to deltas
scaler.com
so thanks for watching this and I'll
catch you tomorrow hopefully hopefully
Wednesday we'll have a bit of activity
in the market but we'll see bye-bye